okay 11:16 yeah yeah 11:16 on February
7th I'm drinking tea it's a Wednesday my
friends Alan was just dropping some
dope-ass knowledge and that's what's
gonna repeat it right now right now
[Music]
what's up so we were just discussing
evolution or discussing simulation
theory and we were thinking about the
insane complexity of everything around
us and how everyone's good at math
because when you think about it whenever
you're trying to cross a crosswalk on
time a street to get the other side of
the street and the signals counting down
from eight seven six five you have to
run a complicated math equation to see
how much distance you need to cover in
those eight seconds that are left and
how quickly your average speed needs to
be in order to get across the street
even though you think you're not good at
math you are good at math because you do
that calculation in your head you figure
it out and there's tons of other
examples like that we'll get there so so
then Alexa was like it's all math and
that's what's why simulation theory is
so exciting which is exactly what we
talked about
so simulation theory is exciting because
the majority of what goes on within us
and outside of us is due to math so and
it's algorithmic so the earth orbits
around the star every 365 days and you
urinate three times a day and poop once
a day and brush your teeth twice a day
your heart beats a hundred thousand
times a day and
that's all algorithmic that's math
similarly to how the star burns with the
certain brightness and so if our star
was a little bit more dim the habitable
zone would be shifted inward towards the
star and so an earth could evolve there
and if the star was more bright than the
have no zone will be shifted outward and
an earth could evolve out there so
there's all these different mathematical
variables that can be tweaked in a solar
system and furthermore the evolution of
the species what we have right here
these flesh vehicles that you see these
flesh vehicles have evolved from
primates and even more so over these
last billions of years from
single-celled organisms because of the
amount of gravitational pull 9.8 m/s^2
again if the earth was larger then our
gravitational pull would be stronger and
we would be shorter our bones and
muscles would need to be convinced where
we can grow up as far and trees can grow
up as far and if the planet was smaller
the mass was smaller the gravity would
be higher and that's not always
necessarily true because it depends on
what's in the core of the actual planet
but if it's a habitable planet like the
earth and has a molten core then it's
usually like this
and so with a the analysis of a solar
system and the analogous Ness how
comparable it is to a atom is absolutely
incredible
the same way that electrons orbit the
center of an atom is similar to how
planets orbit a star and this is all and
this is all this is all math because at
any point the creator of the simulation
is running a massive
an experiment yeah a massive experiment
to see exactly how these different
variables are playing out and it's not
just about gravity and proximity to the
star but it's about behavior
it's about psychology and neuroscience
how do these beings once they get
consciousness how do they actually
interact with one another engage with
one another understand the cosmos that
they are in and furthermore how do they
build their future how many people do
they have to kill first before they work
together so as we think of simulation
theory this is one of my favorite ways
to think of it on this massive
macroscopic and also microscopic scale
and when we do this it usually enriches
us to try and work together better and
to understand the world that we live in
this has been a public service
announcement from Alan sockin from San
Francisco California from planet Earth
in this solar system
alexxa yes until next time we'll be
happening again soon much love
[Music]